هذا مشهد مألوف في جيوش الصين
من العمال المرغوبين والعتاد الواقي الأبيض لكامل الجسم
شنغهاي قد يخرجون من
إغلاقها القاسي لكن الحرب المغطاة في الصين
لم تنته
منذ بدء عمليات الإغلاق في المدن في جميع أنحاء
الصين ، أصبح عمال البدلات الخطرة
رموزًا لكثير من الوحشية والاستبدادية
في مجتمع شنغهاي هذا ، يقوم
عاملة مرغوبة بضرب رجل مرارًا وتكرارًا بعصا ، حيث تقوم
هذه العاملة المرغوبة بدفع
امرأة بقوة على الأرض ، حيث تصطدم
بالرصيف الذي يمسك
رأسها من الألم
في مقطع فيديو آخر ، يركل عامل مرغوب فيه
رجلًا ويضربه على الأرض
و  قام لواء من المنفذين المرغوبين
بسحب هذه المرأة من شقتها
في شنغهاي صرخت بأنها ستذهب
معهم إذا تمكنت من الحصول على حذائها فقط ،
حاولت مقاومتها بكل
قوتها ولكن عبثًا
لم تكن CNN قادرة على التحقق من
هويات  كان الأشخاص المتورطون أو
الظروف في مقاطع الفيديو هذه حتى
لو كانوا جميعًا مرتبطين بالسيطرة على الطمع
ولم تستجب السلطات
لطلبات متعددة للتعليق ، معظم
البيض الكبار هم متطوعون في مجال الرعاية الصحية
وضباط شرطة
يحاولون حقًا مساعدة مجتمعاتهم أثناء
العنف الشديد  من
النادر أن تثير مقاطع الفيديو الفيروسية هذه
غضبًا مما يؤكد
إحباطات الناس المتزايدة تجاه
سياسة الصين الخالية من التغطية.
مع بعض
الضرب والركل بلا هوادة ،
حاول الهرب لكنهم أمسكوا به
واستمروا في إلقاء اللكمات
على الموقع الجغرافي حيث حدث هذا الضرب ،
اتصلت بمركز الشرطة المحلي ،
قاعة وايني
، لذا يبدو أنها شاهدت الفيديو
وهي تعلم أن الفيديو  موجودة تقول إنها
ستتصل بزميلها
الذي سوف يعاود الاتصال بي
لكنني لم أتلقَّ المكالمة مرة أخرى ، لذا حاولت
مرة أخرى
ورأى ما تم بيعه ،
أخبرني أن هذا لم يحدث أبدًا
ثم قام بإنهاء المكالمة.
لقد وصفت صورة سيطرة الطمع
التي تريدها الصين أن
هذه
الدعاية الحكومية مرغوبة بدرجة
أكبر ، إن الأشخاص الذين يطمعون في إنفاذ القانون ،
يشيرون إلى الروبوت اللطيف والقابل للنفخ
من البطل الكبير 6. مرحبًا ، أنا بايماكس
رفيقك في الرعاية الصحية الشخصية مثل
بايماكس البيض ووسائل الإعلام الحكومية
ترفع مقاطع الفيديو من معنويات الناس
رقصاتهم الرائدة في مراكز الحجر الصحي
وتساعد كبار السن حتى على
تسلق السلالم لإجراء اختبارات كوفيد ،
لكن الصورة البريئة للبيض الكبار
فقط من خلال السلوك المروع للبعض
ربما تم تمكينها من خلال عدم الكشف عن هويتهم
تحت بدلاتهم البيضاء.
ضرب
السكان الذين يحاصرونهم في
منازلهم ، وكسر الأبواب لأخذ الناس إلى
الحجر الصحي لتسلق المنازل من خلال
النوافذ لتطهير
حتى ضرب الحيوانات الأليفة حتى الموت ، حتى أن
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الصينية بدأت في
استدعاء منفذي الطمع بالحرس الأبيض
في إشارة إلى الحراس الأحمر
للثورة الثقافية الذين ضربوا بوحشية  تم
تعذيبهم وقتلهم ،
لكن معظم مقاطع الفيديو الوحشية هذه
من البيض الكبار تم إخضاعها للرقابة
من وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الصينية بدلاً من ذلك
هم أبطال رقيقون ،
لكن قسوة البيض الكبير قد
تغلغلت بالفعل في الكثير من العقول التي تهز
إيمان الناس بالحكومة الصينية
الرائعة
سيلينا وانغ cnn بكين